so uh this is this I had this up today I
just move it up to the first thing we
play anyway because of that runoff
he's on the news more candidate Herschel
Walker Herschel great to see you tonight
now what should the priority be for GOP
leadership to be fair I know he is
[ __ ] but there is a delay too there
is
a wooden stake in the hands of every
American immediately I think we got a
real significant vampire problem on our
hands you know the more I've been
researching this issue also this wasn't
a bit he's this is like a platform
running on oh my god well remember you
brought up Senator Van Helsing and he
wants to have an ally in the Senate
he needs to win
Van Helsing I mean this is one of the
reasons we need term limits I mean 1200
years as a senator it's too long it's
too long it's too long
that's almost as long as that bird guy
served almost he's out of touch he
wanted to put four you want to earmark
40 million last year uh in case we get
an extra cold winter and the Bubonic
plague comes back wasn't Senator bird
like the I remember Senator bird was in
the league was it like the last guy to
[ __ ] Lynch a black guy legally or
something and he was still around being
like Oh we want to make a Tuesday
National tobacco day and uh we gotta
prepare uh for the cold winter I believe
a kids are going to get dysentery this
this winter yeah he he still there's a
his uh his press chief he still calls
him boy
he's still he's still trying to push
legislation to [ __ ] ban Indians yeah
like [ __ ] yeah he's the one passing
the miscegenation ACT
um aims to want to cut deals with Chuck
she's the only one asking it was he's
dead now but he wasn't asking about you
about phrenology
uh have you correlated uh the
effectiveness of the vaccine uh based on
the bumps on someone's head I can't tell
you I've never seen that and what is the
width of somebody's nose factor into
their ability is that why they're better
at sports because more air goes in their
nose so they're more oxygenated
oh God we haven't even gotten to
Herschel here oh hi Laura I'm here and
these lights are very confusing
he looks very confused he is yeah let's
go there we go EOP leadership Mitch
McConnell seems to want to cut deals
with Chuck Schumer uh what did you both
call him observably stupid observably
stupid he's observably stupid dude how
but that just goes to show you what how
much of a loser does Raphael Warnock
have to be that's a really good to be in
a deadlock with this guy he's there Dr
Oz
if you think about it because he's in a
runoff now with Herschel Walker Dr Oz
got beat by fetterman he's their Doctor
Oz where it's like unpaid it's like you
should have you should be winning you
should have walked into this why aren't
you
conservatives out there are saying wait
a second you know what about the
principles we care about
well you know I think some of the first
things you should think about is the
reason I decided to run is we the people
not we the government and that's the
problem we have that's one reason I
decided to run had nothing else on a
platform where we're going to be burning
all coffins we can't have coffins around
the capitol we can't because we got
burned the dead or they become the
vampires
I just saw that the Georgia people
that's right it's We the People now we
the government so that is why I'm trying
to become the government
[Music]
what
people are the United States but being
mistreated they're spending out keeps
calling her and Coulter doesn't know
which one which which one he's been
talking to that's fine thank you for
having me on and I'm a big fan they're
like Anna's not been on [ __ ]
television and forever it's not out of
TV deal in years yeah don't have any
money they made us unsafe by giving up
we're calling them Herschel day Walker
Herschel day Walker it was I am so
disappointed that nobody thought it was
right in front of us the entire time see
my mom honestly Virgie I'm gonna fire
you you should have had that one with my
mama yeah I know my mama was pregnant
she was bit by vampire so I became a
half Empire
which is the one with Triple H the third
one
three yeah Trinity Trinity yeah play
Trinity
foot half vampire
and right now let me tell you when the
vampire ran I become Herschel Runner
that's for sure
anytime I had the ball
[Music]
nobody think about being a half vampires
a lot of people think that the daylight
don't bother me but it still really
hurts my eyes and it does bother my skin
kind of like when you spray uh like a
caustic air freshener in there you know
it kind of bother your skin a little bit
right
here at Chuck Schumer talking already
about bringing more people in well we
got to secure this border right now
Fenton is killing fentanyl coming in got
people coming in the Border I have more
people for the vampires to fight than
they become vampires and then next thing
you know we got a country full of bats
my my my immigration part very simple
everyone coming through we give them
garlic bread and they gotta eat the
garlic bread in front of us if you eat
in front of us then we know you're not
available
our young people from 18 to 45 and I
think you need new leadership we need
new leadership so we need a brain dead
form around we need a guy who was dumb
for an NFL player
[Applause]
I really wanted to paint a picture for
the folks at home all right as a
football fan right historically speaking
unless their quarterbacks are pretty
stupid yes even for a football player
Herschel Walker was never known for
being a brilliant insightful mind
so Herschel Walker PhD I mean there's a
reason he's not a coach there's a reason
he's not Dr Herschel Walker in these
former NFL player Herschel Walker
he's not analyst there's a walker oh my
God because he you're right because some
of them like like you have the ones that
like his Magic's been great and yeah
he's been so [ __ ] great I love him
Romo is always great you know Troy
Aikman even though you know
of the allegations of him are true is
Fitzpatrick of now a permanent one I
think so he's great though because he's
so white trash he's got the beard he's
still got this is funny he still has the
Tampa Bay he went to Harvard that's the
weirdest part about that guy he's the
best I love Johnny I mean he should have
been a better quarterback but I mean
other than that he's pretty cool dude
but I'm going to when I'm going to
Washington I'm going as a leader because
I represent the people of Georgia that's
all I don't care about anything else and
then right now I mean like beside
vampires I care about that big time
that's why we're going to train a
Statewide uh werewolf Brigade
stop the vampires and the people of the
United States need representation and
why or even representation I mean even
that too Empire is some cool people
never forget it I had to go back and
watch that clip I was dude I just had to
hear vampire with them cool it's a
stupidest thing ever question
now your opponent uh Warnock is warning
that something very fishy is afoot about
the looming runoff watch this
I've had to stand up time and time again
when we've seen efforts at the federal
level
and at the state level
to make it difficult for people to use
their voices how is this guy losing it's
again it's he really is their Dr Oz how
is this guy and also to answer what he's
saying so you're an election denier I
mean I I'm trying I'm [ __ ] sick of
deciding what election denial is allowed
and which one's not what's allowed
they're disenfranchising the other black
guy he's black too like forget everyone
could be [ __ ] right the other guy
you're running against is also black and
also Senator Warnock I'm gonna be I'm
gonna
make a wild assumption I know the last
thing you want to do is make wild broad
generalizations about a group of people
that being said I'm going to make a
broad generalization and I'm going to
assume that every single person standing
behind you on that stage
has an ID
has some form of State issue let me ask
you a question that they use for various
array of things buying a cell phone an
EBT card going to get food okay
I mean these are all college people or
something aren't they like in some kind
of you oh it's Union people all right so
they're employed these people Union
people are the polar opposite of college
people it's true but at least their jobs
these people are I'm pretty sure they
have to show their ID to cash their
checks and go to [ __ ] Banks and they
have an ID to be in the union merch you
can't be in a union without a [ __ ]
state ID this whole like suppression
thing look at these Savages behind me
you can expect these people to stand in
a line
they can barely function and they start
getting mad they're like hey man what
the [ __ ] bro you imagine this guy at a
DMV
come on you can't do that he's [ __ ]
so just let him vote several times come
on let him and his dead dad vote
I mean some Republicans are like all
we're asking
all we're asking is that you do what
Florida does dude how how easy is it to
vote here bro amazing boom they scan you
in a little machine they pray about it
for you go in isn't it awesome that the
machine my machine didn't break like 25
of them in Arizona they literally you
show your ID you scan it in a machine
they hand you your ballot you go you
sign off on the machine and then you go
to the [ __ ] thing you fill it out
yeah they feed it into the machine in
front of you annually and it literally
goes Boop and it gives you a little
number and you leave why can't you
people do that it's so easy you have to
show ID here nobody's offended in
Florida everyone I saw online is like
here you go black people white people
Hispanic people old people younger here
you go all right cool let's get it done
why is it so hard
the most suppressive it's really hard to
fortify elections merch we have to have
people have ideas but that's all they
want I just want to be able to stuff
these boxes with names
Hershel are these uh conspiracy theories
well first I don't know what that is
what that means sure it's not like a
conspiracy yes too whatever do you
remember me
you know he's he's continued to try to
separate and divide SB 202 will pass a
long time ago he's known about it so
don't try to train change the rules in
the middle of the game right now we're
on a runoff so do your job get out and
see your people that's what I'm doing
I'm getting out to try to get the people
to get behind me he needs to win
because unlike fetterman
they're gonna let him talk
there is a mo you want to know why
because even though he talks like that a
republican black guy is always going to
be able to talk in the Senate because
it's to be like look we have black
people that's what we always do so let's
be realistic with that all right
if he gets in there he's gonna still
have to talk and I would love that more
than anything I would love Senator
Herschel Walker asking fauci who's been
subpoenaed to answer questions more than
anything in the world oh yeah we were
saying that they're in the [ __ ]
vampire but yeah exactly how great would
that be
me because we need new leadership he's
went to Washington and he's represented
you imagine him trying to just nicely
ask how the vaccine works and fauci just
not being able to really quantify it in
a sentence yeah and it's just him just
just genuinely being like like
good-naturedly confused yeah but I don't
understand how to work then yeah I don't
get it but you still get it but it works
but it works but you still get it and
wait sometimes you can still die from it
and you can still spread it
Dr Felch I got another question why why
come they be selling this thing because
it sounds like it don't work right and
he can't go after anybody can't attack
him
because he's not being mean no I'm just
confused because you say it don't work
and then you're telling me we gotta keep
using it because of work I'm very
confused in it's like a kid it's like a
kid finally figuring out Santa Claus
is chewing on his glasses like this like